we're beginning with a really really
simple idea yeah or if you take a
function and you can work out is through
video and this is no problem we're fed
business all right so if I have a
function I know what extreme is no
ambiguity like it's just gonna be more
powerful you rip down the power to be
okay now if we're to go in reverse write
this process of differentiation going
from a function to the derivative it
doesn't quite work in Reverse it's a
little bit like when you take when you
square it up and then you take square
root right for example it's now is fine
all right you square it and then you
take the square root okay great you come
back to the original number okay
however this doesn't always work right
if you take another like they unify and
then you square it and then you take the
square root you do not end back where
you came from right you know something
about it you're and the magnitude of
that number
another word you know the absolute value
of the number but you actually don't
know everything about it some
information namely the sign has been
lost but you went through this process a
differentiation is just the same when
went from here to here we lost some
information right and I can illustrate
it in this way that's right underneath
here if we went in Reverse if what I
knew was the derivative okay Joey back
clearly Mike was x cubed could be the
original function okay and from now on
instead of say a regional function I'm
just going to say primitive because
that's what it means it's where I came
from okay
it's reasonable to assume okay well
white was actually could be the
primitive okay
however Mike was execute flat is not the
only premium that I could have come from
right I could have come from y equals x
cubed plus any quads the term over here
because when I do this differentiation
step that constant term is going to yeah
it's gonna vanish right it's gone okay
so that course what's this information
that gets lost right now we can visually
demonstrate this and I'd love you to
have a little
we can visually demonstrate this by
showing that this is really part of a
family of functions a family of
primitives right that are all off by a
constant of some kind and it's really
important that we mentioned that number
is a constant it's a printable that
stands for number not a variable
right so therefore on the empty you
either say we're sees a constant or if
you're a bit lazy you don't mind
stomaching a little more notation you
say this C is a real number as opposed
to it's some variable that can flip
around change it's an actual number if
that actual set of numbers right so this
is my way of saying it's a number not a
variable okay sir let's illustrate
really quickly this family of functions
right
why comes execute so we started with we
know what that looks like now every
other member in this family a previous
has exactly the same kind of shape but
it's off by a vertical shift do you see
that in fact this C is really modifying
the wine smoke modify the x at all okay
so for instance if I had y equals x
cubed I could very easily pop up your y
equals x cubed plus where you pick a
number five y equals x cubed plus five
and there's my intercept right now what
I want you to do is to remember what we
looked at taking a graph right and then
underneath underneath that drawing it's
derivative at its second derivative
right it's the first or second period
did we ever ask any questions in terms
of you know when you do your greed for
gradient background see do we ever ask
any questions about the position of the
graph the answer is no we're only ever
interested Oh am i increasing I'd like
increasing them I think
I've got a stationary point and just
because of the graph I've chosen it's
increasing there as well okay
I don't care where up or down it is I'm
gonna make exactly the same statement
about the gradient here because their
derivatives are exactly the same and you
could draw an infinite set of these
kinds of primitives up and down on your
Cartesian plane okay so therefore what
we want to do is we want to try to say
like this process here this reversing
differentiation sometimes it's called a
T differentiation because you're undoing
that process right we're really good
differentiation right we have all these
rules that we've established for doing
this right so it's there's a reason if a
rule takes me from here to here some
kind of rule wants me on take me in the
opposite direction okay so new little
subheading underneath this rules for Ag
differentiation we're going to learn
codify service first let's just rehearse
and regular rule for differentiation
between notes above the one that we used
here my so for instance if y equals some
power of X right next to the power
anything you like okay we know what the
derivative is right just like we did
over here for the particular example N
equals three we bring that power down
out the front so the power and then we
reduce the power by one alright so you
can drink no problem okay but now if I
go at this line here and start from the
derivative right if I say you know I
don't actually know what the original
function was but suppose this is the
derivative where did I come from
right what must have differentiated to
get to this right and the answer it is
well you notice how we let me say it
again brought the power down at the
front and then we reduce the power by
one there were two processes there right
and because what I'm trying to do is
reverse what I just did
I'm gonna do those same two processes
but number one I will do the opposite
and I'm gonna do them in reverse order
okay it's really important that I do
both watch for starters I'm going to
increase the power you notice I had to
decrease the power so first thing I'm
going to do is increase the power right
to differentiate a decrease the power to
a different shape I increase the power
okay that was only one of the steps
though what was the other thing I knew
yes if you I multiply so now I should
divide right now in wanted to make sure
I end up back here I'm dividing by the
new power not the previous power the new
one okay now do you notice the order I
did that it's really important you do
the power first and then you do the
division second okay let me put that in
fact I'm encouraging you to do that as
well
but power comes first and the division
comes second the reason why is because
back here the multiplication came first
and then the power came second you see
we're doing the mid-river voice poured
up if you do them the other way round
you would get the right answer let me
prove to you that this is the case right
I can take this right I can
differentiate this differentiate it with
respect to X what's gonna happen I can't
go through this process I bring the
power at the front like so and then I
reduce the power by one that makes it
yes you see how I'm replicating that
person all over n plus one and just as
we predicted cancel cancel cancel cancel
there's my extend that I was supposed to
end up with okay we've one little
problem remember it's a family of
primitives okay there's a whole bunch of
different option options I could have
come from right so in addition to this
guy
I should nicely and again I'm gonna
state and I should state it every single
time this numbers just appeared right I
need to say what it is it's an actual
real number okay it's a con
okay that was fairly easy in fact that's
the that's the stock standard first rule
that we do it which corresponds to this
let's say we have push this a little
further we know how to do regular powers
what about like the extension of that
was the chain rule rate we know how to
do the chain rule right let me give you
a really simple chamber work okay if y
equals this kind of thing right so I've
got a linear function raised to a power
okay just quickly what's the derivative
from this guy okay I was going to bring
me it the power down the front right I'm
going to reduce the power by one so and
then there's almost out the chain rule
step I differentiate the inside function
right which will just give me a so
that's a little bit messy I like to tidy
it up it stick the a out front okay now
I'm gonna give you a second to try and
fit carefully and then verify just like
I did
if instead this thing is my derivative
and I'm asking where did this come from
what primitive was differentiated to
land to here what would you do it again
be careful do the opposite of the steps
and do them in reverse order I'll give
you a tip here there were two steps
there are three in this one okay give it
a shot I'll give you many to think
change which I'm imagining if this was
my starting point I don't want to go
straight back to here because I knew
what that answer is
so I don't want to pretend this is my
derivative
I want to pretend if this and what must
I do that person let's think about this
because we can think slowly as to
whether this works or not right and let
me try and let me try to highlight this
for you right there were three steps
three steps okay
watch as I differentiate this original
function
okay watch right number one I broke the
power down number two I reduce the power
by one and number three I I
differentiate the inside okay tell me
what I'm actually doing okay now let me
look at those and I'm gonna do them in
Reverse I can't I'm gonna go from three
right I multiplied by a so here I'm
dividing by egg I decrease the part in
there then I multiply by a so I divide
by a step two time three and reverse
right I decrease the power sorry
increase the power and in my last that
was a multiplication so now I'm dividing
now that's a bit missing I can tidy it
up okay let me finish just by saying
this right here's the process right and
I'm not gonna finish it for the chamber
one we will have a look at that on
Friday okay but if I start from here
right differentiating we don't know what
to do with that you see people are here
to climb back up the ladder to do
anti-differentiation right we're doing
all this persistence rebus and
importantly we're adding a constant on I
guess another way of thinking about that
is when I differentiate I remove any
constant right they just sort of
disappear okay well last piece of
notation that you need is you guys know
it we often call this F which would lead
to us coin miss F - right well you could
need something to talk about that one
where you came from and you can't really
you can't really unleash some Pig right
so what they do is and unfortunately
don't end up actually functioning
exactly like dashes so here is the
convention just say that you are you
don't use it but you need to recognize
it this guy up here is generally called
capital F